[Music]
hi I'm welcome to episode number 69 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mendell hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good how are you doing I
am very good I feel relaxed after you
know cloud mix is over yeah yeah we
don't have anything to do right it's
just I just nap now that's just what I
do and google i/o but yeah you know
nothing that we cool we cool now and we
have today a very cool interview with
one of our customers so we're gonna have
Dave emitting from server density will
see exactly what they do they do not do
so dense servers there was a joke there
but we did they they basically build
like a logging and monitoring logging
solution mm-hmm and it's open source
runs on Google cloud platform and they
had a very interesting story of
migrating from from on-premise MongoDB
to big table yep and then after that we
will have our question of the week where
we're looking at latency times across
the gcp network where should I run my
machines so my customers in this area
are the happiest y will answer that
question but before that we have as
usual our cool things of the week and
I'm gonna start with the one that I
brought because I think it's super cool
going on this weekend i watch a bunch of
cloud next aux like I said I was
binge-watching next and one of the talks
actually true of the talks that really
blew my mind were from Martin math tengo
una Martin corner from our team he gave
two talks on Thames to flow they're
called tensorflow and deep learning
without a PhD and it turned very well
because I do not have a PhD and it
basically goes from what are the basics
of stands for flow to training a neural
network with all the works of William
Shakespeare and generating new William
Shakespeare random like fan fiction
William Shakespeare fan fiction with
Daniel network and the result is amazing
he also uses the same technique could
generate Python code so he trains the 10
a flow neural network with the
tensorflow source code and then he
generates neotency flood code it looks
like it would work it would look in
theory oh yeah adding it close it to the
point that it starts with the Apache v2
license on top of the files yeah like it
is actually free amazing it generates
code that looked like that looks like i
could have written it really so you know
also I don't write that good Python so
if we probably can't judge yeah yes but
I go check it out is like two hours of
Compton but it's definitely worth your
time if you are curious about what you
can do with deep learning and you want
to learn from scratch and without
getting too much detail into the
mathematic comes to be handed you just
want to know how to do it cool my cool
thing is the announcement of the data
loss prevention API well yeah I actually
think is really cool when I first
actually stole this I just saw the video
and I was like oh that's really neat and
then I realized it was our product and
which is actually really excited so the
cool thing about this is it's a again a
predefined machine learning tool but
what it does is it will remove and sort
of classify sensitive information so
Social Security numbers credit card
numbers phone numbers also to other
types of sensitive data and you don't
really have to do a huge amount of work
for it so you can just send it at the
API and then it'll send it back going oh
hey let's just reduct all these things
from it which is pretty sweet yeah I I
really so i discovered this thing during
one of the cloud necks keynotes mm-hmm
it was really cool because they show
like like imagine that you're on a chat
right and you're talking to someone and
you're like hey I will need your I don't
know your account number yeah and the
like yeah this is my account number
these my social security number these my
address and these help to find my
children you know like maybe not give me
that but now it's running the chat so
you're storing it and with this I with
this API basically you're able to find
all the things that are sensitive and
filter them out so you can now give
access only to the people that should be
having access to this the amazing thing
is that also works on images I don't
know if you saw that oh I didn't see
that yeah they they have an example
where they put a picture and the picture
is a picture of a credit card right and
and the credit card it removes only the
credit card number but not the name of
the person to the name of person is not
considered as sensitive but yeah then
credit card number is so it is Hayes
pretty cool it is really really
experiencing I guess that that's one of
the things that you can do when you have
amazing deep learning with tens of love
yes exactly to the one before and we
have one more cool thing of the week and
I'm gonna say that is this really cool
not just kidding oh do you know how to
make friends don't you just kidding just
kidding I think it's it is very cool and
it is pretty exciting that we have PHP
721 on Google App Engine awesome yeah so
if PHP is your thing and you're looking
to use the latest version of PHP in your
App Engine apps you can now deploy HP
7.1 on App Engine flex it's got built in
containers and built-in cooling there so
you can just get that up and running
really really fast as well as using
pretty much all of your favorite
frameworks from laravel symphony
wordpress and more yeah fair warning I
guess this is a app engine flexible
environment which you know it is pretty
cool and it is now not beta its general
ability since cloud next we announced
that so go have a look and if you're not
into PHP you know there's some people
like that there's many other languages
that you can run on App Engine flexor
got to get out like if you're running
nodejs or Ruby or whatever we have we
have easy ways to run that code also on
Google App Engine flexible environment
yep I don't like a quick shout out one
of the people who sits next to us in the
office Brent Schafer he wrote the blog
post hi Brent this is a really it's a
really nice blog post and there's also a
really great video in there about
deploying PHP applications on App Engine
he says he listens to the podcast let's
see he actually that slide out great so
I guess it's time to go talk to Dave
emitting from server density let's go do
that I'm very very excited today to
welcome our guest David mitten CEO and
co-founder of server density how are you
doing David I'm good yeah how are you
doing great very excited about all the
things that you have to tell us I'm i
always love architecture talks and and i
think that you have a lot
about that but before we get into all
the details well then you toss a little
bit about yourself and what do you do at
several density yeah sure so I'm the
co-founder and CEO at seven density we
are software as a service based scalable
infrastructure monitoring company so we
help customers save time and money by
providing advanced server and website
monitoring so that's alerting waking
people up in middle of night when stuffs
going wrong fancy graphs and
integrations across all the cloud
providers and we've got some customers
like the NHS with the emergency response
service and ambulances here in the UK
and also drupal firebox and as opposed
the graphing is what we're going to be
talking about a bit cool and like so
what do you do at zero density so I
started the company back in 2009 so at
that point I was doing everything I'm
along with my co-founder who I was
working on the design and the interface
and we put a lot of time and effort into
that building our own graphing the
interface and but I built the original
version of the product including our
original time series database and over
the years of hired engineers who are
actually qualified and have rewritten
most of our most of the code that I
wrote in the old days and so now I'm
responsible for us was the overall
company vision are we execute on things
and working on the commercial side as
well as dipping in here and there on the
engineering cool so could you tell us a
little bit about what is server density
like like how it is to use it do you
have an API and people just call for
every single log line the you open a TCP
connection how is there the experience
the developer experience with server
density so there's two different parts
to the product the first one and the
original use cases server monitoring and
then that's complemented by availability
monitoring and with the server
monitoring side of things there's an
open source agent so I wrote the
original version of that and it's
packaged up and you install it on to
your servers it runs it execute commands
to pull in the system statistics and
ties in with all the applications you
might be running on the server so
databases web servers that kind of thing
and it then creates a payload in JSON
sends the data back to us over HTTPS and
that comes into the server density
platform from there it runs through an
alerting engine and that's where we will
decide if the alerts that you've
configured as a customer are going to be
triggered whether we're going to email
you SMS you send messages through to
slack or HipChat or anything like that
and then it routes it to the time series
storage engine so that we can store that
data for historical reporting at
building graphs and showing up
dashboards and then the second part is
the availability monitoring and we have
locations around the world that's where
we will pull your api's when public
applications endpoints anything that's
available online will looking at the
availability and the performance and
then everything is accessible to our
mobile apps our web interface and also
through our API nice so one of the
things that depress me out of the whole
thing that you said was you two to log
stuff your open source agent when it
does it says it sends Jason payload over
HTTP and I'm wondering why why is that
why not like something like GOP see
other than the fact that of course when
you created the agent GOP see was
another thing but like any other option
binaries or whatever so the main there
are two main reasons the first one is
the HTTP is a very well-known protocol
and outbound HTTPS because we encrypt
their payload is typically available on
most environments or if it's not
directly available then often there's a
proxy and avoiding a custom protocol
means that it's very easy to convince
people to open firewall rules if they
need to for outbound connectivity and
then the second reason is in the early
days I didn't really know much about
scaling head scaling services getting
web services but I did know about how to
set up load balancers and to scale web
and I thought that it would be easier to
scale something just by using lobe
answers and apache at the time now
engine x
and then inventing a custom protocol so
you talked a little bit about before you
said you set up the original
implementation of our server density
works can you talk us a little bit
through that I believe you weren't
running on Google Cloud you're doing
some other different things yes that's
right so there's a couple of different
steps and we have migrated a large
portion of the app application over to
Google Cloud but there's still a few
bits in our our older infrastructure
that's gradually being moved over over
the next few months but I can talk about
the how it was before and then we can go
into all the cool stuff on google cloud
by how it is now sounds good so when the
payload comes in or when it came in
through our system it goes into the
intake part of the application so this
is just an endpoint and HTTPS endpoint
and the data comes in and that is then
passed through our load balancers which
were Apache in the original days and are
now running off engine X and that is
inserted into a queuing system which we
built on top of MongoDB the data is
stored there and then very quickly is
pulled out by the rules engine the
original version of that was in PHP that
was the first language that I had learnt
and it has a bad reputation but is
incredibly versatile and being able to
do stuff really quickly so the rules
engine looks of the payload does quick
check to make sure it's about a JSON and
the account exists the account is fully
paid up and is active and then it will
pass through all the data and compare it
to the alerts that are configured and we
do a number of different checks to see
if an alert is already open if it is
already open then we might not want to
send another notification immediately
and there are different rules that allow
us to send notifications at different
times once an alert has been opened or
waiting for a certain period of time for
an alert condition to exist for a couple
of minutes before we send notifications
but it's all based on customer
configuration if we decide to send a
notification then there's a separate
queue again in our MongoDB base queue
and our notification service which has
been rewritten
to python and that was the second
language that I learnt and that is what
sends emails and SMS is ties into push
notification gateways and sends that out
to the customer and then there's a
second route which goes into MongoDB for
the time series storage as well so
that's for the graphing and the
reporting so these two channels one for
alerting and where goes through the
rules engine and then we discard it then
it's the second channel where it goes
into the time series format is
transformed into an optimized storage
format and then goes into MongoDB so
this was that this was the previous
implementation read there was running
all these MongoDB instances is that
right yes that's right and that was
running on bare metal servers at
softlayer and we had hundreds of
gigabytes of ram many terabytes of SSDs
and it was several years worth of
iterations on that that I did in the
very beginning to give us really really
fast loading graphs for was the most
commonly accessed time view which is
usually the last couple of hours up to
the last 24 hours for customers and then
is slightly less optimized in terms of
the the graph loading time for time
periods going beyond that so I'm curious
now so were you running like your own
sort of shadowed MongoDB replica sets
how are you managing that like was that
all just a manual process how is that
managed yeah it was the MongoDB replica
sets with sharding so there was a single
database and a single collection in
MongoDB and that we split it out into
different granularities so the agent
reports back every minute and we store
that data every minute for for a week
and then it's also at the same time
written into a different database to
give hourly averages and that data is
stored forever and due to the
architecture of MongoDB at the time the
database level lock that they had which
has now been improved significantly in
the latest storage engines we split the
merge into different databases and
shouted them separately but aside from
that being a kind of a limitation of of
[ __ ] it also allowed us the benefit of
being able to split them out into
different clusters based on
the use case because hourly data is
accessed less often and so we could have
cheaper hardware to power lacklustre
well so you were mentioning that that is
previous architecture so what about the
new one what were the issues or what
were the advantages on the new yorka
teacher that made you move yeah so there
were a couple of challenges and we
reached these as thinking about a year
ago to the beginning of last year and we
got to the point where the current
system was no longer scaling in
particular we had to spend a lot of time
maintaining that infrastructure so we
didn't own the servers but they were
bare metal servers and we're renting
them from softlayer and every software
we'd have disk failures or hardware
failures and we'd have to deal with
upgrading them and so there was just a
lot of time consuming maintenance that
our team had to do we also wanted to
build a lot more features and because
we'd completely custom designed the
essentially the database schema to fit
this and the API is all the
functionality and the whole architecture
around it and it was a completely custom
system and we're a small team with 20
people majority of them are engineers
but we have so many feature requests
coming in that we didn't have enough
time to dedicate to building I'll
spending all our time building and
time-series data functionality so things
are doing maths functions and being able
to pull out data from different
granularities and combine it all the
aggregations all of these standard
features that you'd expect be able to
see which didn't have time to build them
then also that has scaling was a
challenge so the replication and scaling
in MongoDB is pretty good but you can't
do it in a linear fashion you have to
set up an entirely new cluster for a new
shard and then data has to move around
and migrate you've got to make sure that
there's enough overhead and two to move
that data and so adding new clusters in
was an overhead and then finally it's
very expensive to buy all that memory
and all those SSDs and it was a fun
thing to say that we've got terabytes of
SSDs but
and when you're actually looking at the
overall cost it was really expensive
excellent all right so what is the new
architecture look like I think you're on
gcp now woody what are you using what
what's connected to what yeah that's
right so the time series database that
was MongoDB is now cloud big table and
that is running I am obviously on google
cloud but the intake aspect of it is
still in software it's just in a new
architecture and I was about 18 months
ago two years ago that we rewrote that
bit and unfortunately the pub sub
product wasn't fully available so we
ended up having to build it ourselves on
top of Kafka and storm so to go back to
how the data comes in so it's coming in
from the agent it goes into that intake
part again so instead of it going into a
MongoDB q it now goes into Kafka so CAF
codes the apache open source project
queuing system that's then pulled out
using storm which is a big data event
based processing system it's basically
gives us a framework to process all that
data the rules engine was rewritten from
PHP into Python that's the language that
we've standardized across the whole
company and new things are written in
Python now and so all the rules engine
and was replicated in Python and with a
modern test suite and integration tests
and everything that you'd expect from a
properly planned and written project
rather than something that I wrote and
it's scaled over the years and then the
notification system again that first
root is still the same with some
improvements but that's in Python still
and then the second root is the entirely
new bit on top of Google cloud platform
so part of this was also a mite is also
the first bit of our migration over to
Google Cloud so we had the challenge of
running the primary infrastructure in
soft layer but having the time series
data base running on Google cloud
platform and what we have to do is
because the system is built in a
microsomes architecture then we have all
these api's internally and so it was
relatively straightforward to extract
this entire component move over to
Google and have it continue to
communicate over HTTPS
even across the internet which is what
we did so that second route now looks
like i'm just an internal api exposed
over https and that goes into the google
load balancers that gives us the high
availability and the scalability the
internal api is written in python again
and it's just exposing the functionality
it's a very light wrapper on top of open
TS DB which is the time series database
product that we use this is open source
and has allowed us to solve that problem
of not having enough time to build all
the features that we want into the time
series database because it has so many
different features available out of the
box that we're now starting to build
into the product and we've been able to
contribute a few fixes Beck as well
because it's an open source project and
then the final part of it is that open
TS DB is talking to Clyde big table and
that's where the actual storage of the
data sets cool tell us a little bit
about how is open tsb works and like how
that whole thing kind of goes together
I'm quite curious about it yeah so the
open TSD be instances entirely stateless
so we're running backs on a Google
container engine so it's I have a shiny
new containers running on Cuba Nettie's
which was a lot of fun too for our team
to play around with but it essentially
gives you an optimized storage format
and which is has a driver to install
that into a cloud big table and then
gives you an API to be able to query the
data and has various functions so you
can aggregate and perform math functions
on top of the data and it's all queried
based on on tags so this gives us all
those features that we wanted in terms
of being able to offer the graphing to
our customers and how how's the
experience being in terms of being able
to scale big table has that worked for
you so the best part of it probably is
that it's a completely managed service
and this was one of the biggest reasons
for us moving over so the winner wrote
the original version of our MongoDB
system I chose MongoDB because there was
nothing else available a big table
didn't exist as a publicly available
product
and databases like Cassandra which have
a good reputation for time series data
and didn't exist the first time I came
to work with MongoDB and so it gave us a
really good product that scaled over the
years had to have really really fast
rates and I'm surprised at how well it's
scaled over well seven years really of
the company existing but it required a
huge amount of my time and then and when
hide people which required a lot of time
internally to continue to maintain it
and so just being able to have a
database product that's managed by
Google all the failover the redundancy
the design everything is just handled by
Google so that we don't have to deal
with any of that and it's not a
general-purpose database is very
specifically designed for time series
data and that means we get incredible
performance from it and that allows us
to reduce the cost just because we don't
need all that expensive hardware and
then specifically in terms of this
capability it's essentially linear we
know that we can get 10,000 writes per
second per node and we just press a
button and in a couple of minutes we
have a new node and within about 20 to
30 minutes the data has rebalanced
across the entire cluster and we've
added an extra ten thousand rights could
you share a little bit of the amount of
traffic that you doing or what's a
different cast between running your own
servers ooh saying that you were owning
so many SSDs to just migrate everything
to cloud big table yeah so the the cost
of cloud big table is a lot more
predictable because we can see exactly
how many writes per second we're buying
for the per node cost and the graphing
that the Google cloud platform control
panel provides is pretty good and it
just shows us the absolute numbers that
means we can see pretty easily the exact
number of writes that we're doing and
how we need to scale it when it came
down to MongoDB in the previous
architecture it was not as transparent
in terms of being able to see where
we're at in terms of the scalability
there's
no direct correlation between the number
of rights and the hardware that we have
and so we have to do a lot of
benchmarking and testing and typically
we would see that we needed to scale
through proxy metrics like the response
times of the API is rather than actually
know knowing that we're hitting the
limits of the rights and that the the
product can provide well so I'm actually
curious are we talked about what's
seemingly all the good stuff were there
any interesting challenges or issues
that you ran into moving over to gcp in
BigTable and the new architecture yes so
there were two interesting situations
that are worth talking about so the
first time that we we started the the
test workload on to a big table and we
did some tests in MongoDB and looked at
the number of metrics that we're writing
per second and then stimulated some test
traffic into big table to see if that
Lee was truly like the theory actually
played out and we saw that we were doing
hundreds of thousands of rights per
second more than we actually predicted
and that completely blew away our cost
calculations because you get 10,000
writes per second per node and you just
pay per node and it looked like we were
going to go in two to three hundred
nodes on BigTable which would have been
cool to say and was fun discussing with
your engineers but and then we
discovered the open TSD be shipped with
an outdated driver and it was released
before you released a new batch API and
so you engineered suggested that we
upgrade to a test version of the of the
driver which we did and in our test
workload which was doing a hundred
thousand writes per second as soon as we
switched over to the new driver it went
down to three thousand writes per second
Wow a pretty significant difference it
was a big relief that our actual
calculations were correct and our
original cost projections were correct
then the second lesson that we learned
from that was to do with the keys and
this is really important when you're
querying the data so the original key
was based on an account ID so
account within server density gets a
unique ID and then also the metric name
and the more items that we have in our
account the more data that had to be
queried and by item I mean like a server
so if we were looking for load average
for example then the original key was to
look at the account ID and then look at
load average but that would query across
every single server within the account
and so we're not performance testing
that quickly revealed that we'd made a
mistake with the query with a key query
design and we needed to be much more
granular because for are really small
accounts it was fine but for our
accounts were thousands and thousands of
servers the response time was just
completely unacceptable and so we played
around with a few different options and
the obvious one was just to drop in the
the item ID in the middle so instead of
it just being account ID and then the
metric name it became account ID item ID
and then the metric name and that
reduced query times from 30 to 40
seconds in some cases down to less than
a second in most cases which is much
more acceptable when you're just loading
a dashboard yeah nice yeah I guess it
that is one of the things that I've
heard many times about big table big
table is after all a key value store
forget fancy wanted it but like
basically key value store so i guess
that choosing the keys is a very very
important part of it is there any other
aspects of like any best practices that
you may share something that you learn
say hey like this is how you should be
doing keys other than what you just
mentioned i think the key to designing
the right the key set up is to actually
test it and we tested with small data
sets to begin with and it was only when
we then started testing with the
production simulation that we discovered
this performance problem which in
hindsight is pretty obvious and it's
something that could easily be picked up
but it was just just a simple mistake in
not having a diverse enough testing set
and that i suppose is also similar to
the
we had with the driver in the once you
start putting production workload
through it that's where it really shows
up the problems otherwise you would just
assume just a couple of thousand writes
per second as a test workload am is a
reasonably sized workload for many
people but as soon as you start pushing
like actual production data through
that's when these little things will
show up cool all right well we're slowly
running at a time here is there anything
we haven't asked you or anything you
want to mention or a plug or anything
like that before we finish up I am so I
think the only thing would be the human
ops community that I started and now
running in the US and also in Europe
which is there's come out of my
experiences in the early days of seven
density being on call 24 hours a day for
a couple of years and but now more
recently talking to our customers and
it's a community and a series of meetups
where we get companies and individuals
to come along and talk about how they're
running the human side of their
operations so we tend to focus on all
the cool shiny tools and systems we have
in place but don't pay enough attention
to the humans are running the systems in
the sense of fatigue getting too many
alerts or the stress of being on call
and how different companies deal with
that so we've run an event in San
Francisco and we're doing one in April
in New York and we're also running one
in London so please have a look on human
ops calm nice and since we've talked
about events it seems they will see you
at cloud next yes that's right on 8th of
March I'm going to be speaking about
this about the migration I've got some
cool architecture diagrams so you can
visualize what I've just been talking
through and we'll see and I've also got
the graph of that change to the the
driver with a massive drop from 100,000
down to 3,000 writes per second sounds
awesome great well thank you so much for
joining us today David that was a super
interesting conversation excellent thank
you so thanks again to David for a
second interesting interview it was pre
aligning to be able to see how someone
could go from such a huge traffic
running a MongoDB on-premise to
migrating all of that
like basically while the i think that
the metaphor is changing the engine on a
car while it's moving or something like
that i think people generally say train
but yeah that works it doesn't matter
that it still works as a metaphor on the
on the i tell you on the train is easier
because you can just rip it but whatever
it is that's not the important thing it
was a very interesting very interesting
thing and if you're interested in
knowing more about this this interview
was recorded right before next but
during next they had a very cool session
called big table in action powering
billion users services and meeting
customers challenges and it is available
online so you can go check it out now
and you'll see Sammy so heard in from
here from google clock he's a senior
solutions senior solutions architect and
also david maiden which our friend which
is interviewed which is the CEO of a
server density and finally anthony foxx
which is the actor of data science CCRI
so go check it out there's a lot of good
lessons to be learned in there so yep
now always love really interesting
stories where people have moved from one
place to another and why they did that
super super interesting stuff yeah it's
definitely war stories that you know
there's failures in there unless it's in
there that you could learn so you can
avoid them so go check it out fantastic
well why don't we move on to our
question of the week today's question of
the week we want to talk about ping
times yes so you're building your next
amazing application and you say to
yourself which regions should I put this
in for Google cloud platform which ones
are going to give me the lowest latency
so is there an easy way to be able to
find out what my latency could be not
only there's an easy way but it has an
amazing name it is GC ping so like gcp
but with ing at the end and which also
its ping so you know Jesse pinkham and
it is a very simple service it is
created by by somewhere working at
Google JSON hole he just made these
available a very simple service has one
f1 micro instance running every single
one of our region's and basically just
shows you the
average pink time from your laptop or
whatever you using maybe your phone to
all of those instances and it's pretty
cool like for instance right now for me
I can see that from San Francisco the
shorter spin is us West one which is you
know not surprising but I was actually
surprised that europe west one is
slightly longer than Asia East one which
kind of makes sense because Asia East is
just the ocean so we have a cable going
through but us where's one there's
actually need to go through the United
States and then throw yeah there's like
mountains and stuff in the way yeah so
it kind of makes sense right didn't
think about it like if I'm flying
actually I'd say the Paris is shorter
than then Hong Kong mmm apparently that
doesn't come with the sales we have but
one thing I really like about this is
there's a global role in there so what
he does is he set up a global HTTP load
balancer which will then route request
the nearest healthy instance so what's
neat about that is you can actually see
that ok so for ya for me again same in
San Francisco us one I get about twenty
eight milliseconds and your mileage may
vary for obvious reasons but then my
global is 31 milliseconds so there's a
small difference as it goes through the
load balancer there of a few
milliseconds but you can pretty much
determine where it's actually routed you
to the correct place that is closest to
you yeah it is very cool because you can
imagine that if you want your incense to
be accessible from like your application
to be accessible and fast everywhere in
the world yeah you need to have a global
HCP load balancer hmm that that's the
answer basically yep yep if you are
depending on a specific region just yeah
do you see pink come and you can see
which one is the closest one cool all
right France asked where are you off to
what are you up to what are you doing so
I'm gonna be recording one more episode
actually I just released an episode of
just a funk again so for those that do
not know what just for funk is is this
youtube series that have been creating
for quite a while now and I just
finished with flappy gopher so now we
have a like a clone of flappy flappy
bird branning complete lingo I'm pretty
fun episode is cute yeah yeah
and then I'm going to be doing a neck
another one soon but right after that
I'm going to China I'm going to Shanghai
to speak at gopher con China and also
gonna go gonna be running some workshops
they're still not completely plan but if
you are in the region around Shanghai
definitely check it out because I'll be
trying to do some go and urban areas
workshops sweet what about you so I'm
heading off to Vancouver I'll be there
for the way Kyle Bass to be working out
of Vancouver for a bit but while I'm
there I'll be doing a polyglot to
Vancouver talk i'll be talking at gr pc
and crew benetti's i will say if
anyone's in vancouver and their stuff
that you think i should check out or do
or tech stuff or anything along those
lines or presentations you might want
made drop me a line dm's are open on
twitter outside of that i will be the
east coast games conference talking
about game servers and crouppen at ease
i'm in shortly after that i will be a
vector that will be from the 18th of
april onwards nice if you if you want
things two doing in vancouver I have
some very good recommendations for
restaurants is a good yes bhangra fruit
is except well um I think it's been a
while since we have not done fees okay
but I'm gonna try to reverse the roles
is I'm so you're gonna say where and I'm
gonna say how okay so what's the website
GC the vodkas come the email address
hello a DC podcast welcome twitter at GC
broadcast read it / r / DC podcast a
google+ plus GC podcast slack uh oh wow
yeah that one that one's not gonna make
it like the ash podcast hash podcast in
the Google cloud platform community that
you can access through beat Dudley / gcp
dash slack exactly what I said exactly
uh so there you go if you have any
proposals questions we still looking for
more questions on the week we did less
episode with that question of the week
that was recording someone if you send
us a recording with your question we
will definitely use it that it is always
fun to
you're our listeners so send those our
way and as always thank you Mark for yet
another amazing episode and thank you
France ask for joining me for yet
another episode and thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
you